zu seinem zdf heute live ihr mit euren
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
im livestream wo wir uns immer freuen
wenn ihr mit diskutiert und das thema um
das es heute geht ist ein heiß
diskutiertes thema schon lange den seit
zweieinhalb wochen sind wir ja wieder in
der phase der kontakt beschränkungen
aber die ergebnisse reichen der politik
nicht aus letzte woche wurde schon
darüber diskutiert zwischen
bundesregierung und den bundesländern ob
man die maßnahmen jetzt verschärfen
wollte die bundesregierung wollte das
gerne
die länder haben gesagt nee bitte
erstmal nicht wir belassen es bei
appellen aber diese woche könnte es doch
kommen
seit gestern gibt es in der
beschlussvorlage der
ministerpräsidentinnen die kursiert und
darin wird von maßnahmen verlängerung
des zwanzigster dezember gesprochen und
auch von einigen maßnahmen verschärfung
was genau konkret kommen wird das können
wir noch nicht sagen das wird am
mittwoch beschlossen oder besprochen
zwischen bundesregierung und den
bundesländern aber generell kann man
schon mal sagen dass nicht alle diese
pläne und überhaupt die maßnahmen die
wir jetzt haben gut finden auf der einen
seite zum beispiel die opposition die
fdp hat gesagt wir sollten eigentlich
gucken dass wir bis ins frühjahr planen
aber es gibt auch eine gruppe von
wissenschaftlerinnen die noch weiter
gehen
die sagen ganz elementar so wie sie die
daten zur zeit erheben das funktioniert
so nicht das ist alles viel zu grob
gerechnet wir wissen gar nicht wie die
pandemie genau verläuft und wir brauchen
mehr zahlen um dann auch gezielte
maßnahmen zu ergreifen und nicht einfach
quasi mit der groben flinte auf alles zu
schießen einer von denen ist professor
matthias schrappe internet
universitäts-professor unter anderem für
qualitätsmanagement interessierte
medizin patientensicherheit
risikomanagement mit denen möchten wir
uns gleich sprechen über seiner kritik
die er und seine kolleginnen haben und
natürlich mit euch über eure kritik eure
fragen und anregungen zum thema bitte
gerne in die dafür vorgesehenen in die
dafür vorgesehene kästchen schreiben
oder hier einmal per e mail an zdf heute
- live at zdf.de das wird dann zu mir
weitergereicht so aber jetzt sprechen
wir natürlich erst mal mit
professor matthias schrappe internet und
universitäts professor wie schon gesagt
sie haben die maßnahmen der regierung
schon länger kritisiert professor
schrappe was ist denn ihre generelle
kritik an der an den maßnahmen die wir
zurzeit haben sehr guten abend danke für
die frage was ist wahr
seit acht monaten schreiben wir
regelmäßig papiere versuchen uns
verständlich an die politik zuwenden
natürlich auch an die allgemeine
öffentlichkeit und wir haben zwei große
kritikpunkte in die von anfang an von
februar an eigentlich ganz aktuell sind
eins ist wie kommen wir eigentlich zu
zahlen die und zuverlässig sagen wo wir
stehen das zweite ist jede präventions-
anstrengungen der epidemie hat immer
zwei beinen auf der sie steht stehen
muss ein bein ist die einschränkung der
kontakte das ist so ähnlich wie wir das
auch gemacht haben aber das andere was
fehlt komplett
da muss ich nämlich speziell um die
kümmern die von einer epidemie besonders
betroffen sind
bei manchen epidemien sind es kinder bei
manchem epidemien sind es alte in
unserem fall wie wir ja
wir wissen sind das alter mit
vorerkrankungen
betroffene patienten personen die einem
besonderen risiko ausgesetzt sind und ja
wenn es gut gelaufen wäre hätten wir uns
frühzeitig darum gekümmert hier
stichwort pflegeheime für
schutzmaßnahmen zu sorgen das ist
unterblieben und das ist ein
schwerwiegender kritikpunkt von unserer
seite dem wir immer wieder vorgebracht
haben wir jetzt in die frage ungeklärt
ist tiefen ihrer kritik einsteigen
möchten wir uns vielleicht einmal
anschauen was dort am mittwoch
beschlossen werden könnte an
weiterführenden maßnahmen oder auch an
verlängerungen da ist ja einiges in der
diskussion das hat mein kollege lassen
bohnsack für uns einmal zusammengefasst
hildburghausen hält einen traurigen
spitzenplatz inne
der thüringer landkreis ist krone
hotspot nummer eins mit einem aktuellen
incidence wert von 386 tendenz steigend
wir haben hier flächendeckend neue
infektionen und es ist nicht nur auf
eine einrichtung beschränkt auf die
schulen kindergarten auf eine feuerwehr
auch der rettungsdienst sonders ist
flächendeckend an dass die bisherigen
maßnahmen ganz offensichtlich nicht
reichen ist mittlerweile auch den
verantwortlichen politikern klar die
steile kurve der infektionen gebrauchen
aber noch viel zurückzahlen
das ist die grundmittel wählen ich
glaube die bestreitet auch keiner cdu
und spd geführte länder sind sich
weitgehend einig welche zusätzlichen
maßnahmen sie ergreifen wollen
so sollen kontakte auf maximal fünf
personen aus zwei haushalten beschränkt
werden an den schulen soll die masken
pflicht erweitert werden und die
november hilfen für die wirtschaft
werden verlängert wir haben alle
miteinander das allergrößte interesse
daran mit möglichst niedrigen zahlen aus
diesem jahr heraus zu kommen wenn das
wird es uns leichter machen dann auch im
nächsten jahr dann hoffentlich
allmählich wieder günstigeren
bedingungen dann tatsächlich die
kontrolle über das virus zu haben aus
der opposition kommt die kritik dass den
maßnahmen der lange
er empfehle es wird doch im januar und
im februar genauso kalt wenn nicht sogar
kälter sein als im dezember und deswegen
wäre es besser bis mitte märz sich auf
maßnahmen zu verständigen
am mittwoch kommen länderchefs und
bundesregierung zusammen um über die
verschärfungen zu beraten
ein erneutes scheitern können sich beide
seiten nicht leisten und darüber möchten
wir sprechen mit dem universitäts
professor und internisten professor
schrappe von der uni köln
ich habe meine ganz grundsätzliche frage
herr professor schreibe ich habe mir mal
angeguckt wer mit ihnen zusammen dieses
maßnahmen papier dieses thesenpapier
geschrieben hat und da komme ich zur
pflege managerinnen zu
allgemeinmedizinern zu medizinrechtler
medizin soziologen juristen
rechtsmedizinern da sind keine
epidemiologen und keine virologen dabei
wieso eigentlich nicht
ja ich bin infektiologie ich habe dass
die infektiologie hier in köln eine uni
klinik aufgebaut
in der zeit als hiv uns große probleme
gemacht hat
ansonsten kann ich nur sagen unser
ansatzpunkt ist seit gerade dass wir
viele fachgebiete auch viele
professionen dass wir jemand von der
pflege dabei haben
das ist gerade unser ansatzpunkt weil
wir weil man ja sieht dass das reine
vertrauen auf biologen die versuchen
sozusagen die epidemie unterm mikroskop
zu bekämpfen und epidemiologen die vom
computer sitzen und modelle rechnen
die sache nicht beherrschen können
sondern muss es leute geben die aus
verschiedensten perspektiven heraus die
dinge wirklich in die hand nehmen die
sich um die grundrechte kümmern die sich
um die infektiosität von infektions
übertragen über türklinken kümmern die
das aus der pflege perspektive kennen
aus der arzneimittel perspektive das ist
sehr wichtig auch aus der staatlichen
und politischen perspektive so haben wir
unsere gruppe zusammengesetzt und
erhalten sie gerade deswegen
für ein muster für ein herangehen an so
eine epidemie einer epidemie ist nie nur
eine medizinische oder gar nur
virologische angelegenheit ist ihnen da
der blick der bundesregierung zu tunnel
artig dass sie nicht breit genug schaut
ja das war von anfang an unsere massive
kritik die sehr ernst gemeint
virologen sind mit denen habe ich sehr
viel auch persönlich gearbeitet sind ist
eine wichtige disziplin nur für eine
epidemie braucht man leute die vor ort
gehen die wie gesagt wie das ja ein
virologe aus bonn auch gut gemacht hat
der dafür dann aber angegriffen wurde
nämlich sich um die frage zu kümmern ja
wie ist es denn genau mit der
übertragung dass beispielweise sagte mit
den türklinken das war im märz die ja
eine der beiden wichtigsten fragen die
es überhaupt zu beantworten gab und das
kann man nicht unterm mikroskop machen
sondern dann muss man vor ort gehen
diese techniken die man kennt bei der
bekämpfung von epidemien
da haben wir ja spezialisten in
deutschland wir haben 700.000 kann als
infektionen im jahr und da gibt es viele
sehr gut ausgebildete leute die das
kontrollieren können von denen ist
keiner gefragt worden aber können wir
nicht feststellen wenn wir mal
europaweit gucken wie es so aussieht
gerade was die infektionszahlen angeht
was die sterblichkeit angeht dass wir
eigentlich relativ gut durch die krise
kommen und dass man wenn man jetzt
kritisiert dass doch auf relativ hohem
niveau macht na ja also ich finde die
10.000 darüber liegende zahl von
todesfällen nun also dann keinen allzu
großen grund zum jubeln wir haben
sicherlich in deutschland gerade über
die hohe zahl von intensivbetten relativ
gute ausgangsbedingungen gehabt und
außerdem diese epidemie ist ja von süden
und von westen über europa herein
gebrochen hatten wir einfach auch eine
woche länger zeit um uns vorzubereiten
eine epidemie ist immer etwas was das
gesundheitssystem spiegelt wenn bergamo
an wenn ich eine epidemie gesehen
sondern ein zusammenbrechen des
gesundheitssystem was mangelhaft
vorbereitet war und was das typische
geboten hat dass die patienten die
krankenhäuser kamen die mitarbeiter
angesteckt haben wir mitarbeiter haben
andere patienten angesteckt und das
ganze endete in wenigen tagen in einer
absoluten katastrophe
sowas haben wir abfangen können weil wir
ein bisschen mehr zeit hatten aber das
heißt nicht dass wir jetzt die epidemie
mit einer relativ einfachen viel zu
einfachen nur auf lockdown setzenden
strategien den griff bekommen
sie haben jetzt schon die sechste
version ihres thesenpapiers publiziert
haben da immer wieder auch nachjustiert
meine kollegin nina niebergall hat uns
mal den gefallen getan sich die sechste
version anzuschauen durchzulesen und für
uns zusammen zu fassen
wir lassen alte und kranke menschen ins
offene messer laufen mit den derzeit in
deutschland geltenden corona maßnahmen
gefährden wir risikogruppen
das sagt zumindest eine gruppe aus neuen
wissenschaftlern
sie fordern einen strategiewechsel
ausgangspunkt ihrer argumentation die
dunkelziffer diese sei hoch also die
zahl derer die infiziert sind oder waren
aber nicht in der statistik auftauchen
das zeigten massentests wie etwa in der
slowakei bei denen ein prozent der
getesteten positiv waren auf
gesamtbevölkerung hochgerechnet kann das
ziemlich viel werden kennzahlen auf die
sich die politik aktuell beruft seien
daher verfälscht und unzuverlässig
die dunkelziffer viel mehr so hoch dass
bei den aktuellen infektionszahlen teile
der bevölkerung bald immun sein könnte
man also von herdenimmunität sprechen
können
aber auf dem weg dahin würden
risikogruppen nicht verschont um das zu
verhindern helfen kontakt beschränkungen
alleine nicht so die wissenschaftler
vielmehr müssten maßnahmen her die
gezielt schützen vor allem diejenigen
die besonders schützenswert sind so und
ihre streamen zu ihrer information
professor schlappe wir gucken halt immer
hier auch in die kommentare da geht es
hoch her
einerseits einmal an meine adresse
gericht sind von reis schule der meint
ich würde hier um die deutungshoheit
kämpfen nein das ist nicht der fall
wir führen hier interessiert kritisches
interview und da habe ich keine totale
deutungshoheit zu erkämpfen oder zu
verteidigen sondern ich möchte wissen
was der professor abgesagt und versuche
andere gegenmeinungen dagegenzuhalten es
gibt aber auch viele kommentare die in
ihre richtung gehen professor strafe zb
von cornelia groß die schreibt man muss
sich wirklich fragen ob die korona
strategie die richtige war
die zahlen gehen trotz lockdown nicht
großartig runter und es wird noch monate
dauern wie konnten sie überhaupt so hoch
steigen hätte man von anfang an
risikogruppen geschützt wird nicht
gleich alles laufen lassen hätten wir
jetzt weniger probleme wobei ich da
jetzt schon sagen würde alles laufen
lassen haben wir nicht oder professor
schreibe wir haben ja im märz doch
relativ alles dicht gemacht sondern das
gegenteil getan
nein nein wir haben schon kontakt
beschränkungen eingeführt und ohne das
geht es auch nicht
und solange die herde dominieren also
die familienfeier die große spiel war ja
das paradebeispiel ist auch die
nachverfolgung sehr wichtig nur im
sommer hat sich das bild geändert wir
sind übergegangen
den so genannten sporadischen typ der
ausbreitung das ist einfach terminus der
beschreibt das in der fläche unentdeckte
infizierte verbleiben das ist bei einer
erkrankung wie saas zwei so weil sie
asymptomatisch auch übertragen wird
nicht nur von kranken die als
symptomatischen träger können wir nicht
aber nicht erkennen
deswegen wissen wir nicht wo sie sind
und aus dieser lage heraus hat sie im
sommer eine situation aufgebaut
das wird plötzlich an vielen ecken
probleme haben ein kollege ist der
gruppe hat das genannt viele kleine
feuer in der fläche sind entstanden und
da muss man mit anderen methoden
spätestens mit anderen methoden
eingreifen die kontakt beschränkungen
sollte man nicht zu viele ja ausbreiten
weil das die nebenwirkungen die
nebeneffekte zu groß sind aber ganz
essenziell ist zu versuchen dass die zu
starke belastung der krankenhäusern in
die station vermieden wird dadurch dass
man sinnvoll und gezielt diejenigen die
einen besonderen risiko ausgesetzt sind
vor der ansteckung und damit vor dem
krank werden
schütz ist einer ihrer hauptkritikpunkte
wie ich das heraus gelesen habe ist ja
immer wieder wir wissen nicht genug über
die pandemie wir haben keine
verlässlichen zahlen
wir wissen nicht wie hoch die
dunkelziffer ist sie fordern da vor
allem kohortenstudien also dass für alle
nicht wissenschaftler eine kohorte ist
quasi einen geboten jahrgang oder
mehrere geburtenjahrgänge zusammen wo
dann immer wieder geschaut wird wie
läuft quasi in zwei drei vier wochen
abstand das kann man quasi selber
festlegen
die gibt es kritisieren sie so nicht ich
hab mal geschaut
mit der hilfe einer kollegin was es an
studien gibt und wenn wir mal auf meinen
rechner schalten das können sie das
gerade nicht sehen wofür strafe aber ich
kann sie ihn beschreiben
da sind wir beim rk ii da gibt es
antikörper studien in ausgewählten
bevölkerungsgruppen und wenn wir hier
mal runter scrollen dann sind das sehr
viele es gibt die bundesliga riverdance
studie ich mache das man
ein größerer dann könnte das besser
sehen es gibt die freiwillige internen
unternehmensstudie von einer von einem
unternehmen es gibt die studie der db
fernverkehr es gibt beim studie des
öffentlichen dienstes bremen in filters
und fördert eine förderung einrichtungen
wird schwer die studien gemacht wenn wir
runter scrollen sehen wir einfach sind
sehr sehr viele studien im gange reichen
die ihnen nicht professor schrappe oder
so dass die falschen
ja das ist jetzt schwer für mich zu
beantworten in einem tonfall der nicht
zu wissenschaftlich ist oder das was sie
schildern wir haben die ja zum größten
teil zitiert und unserem letzten papier
sind halt antikörper studien dass sie
keine geworden studien antikörper
studien die sind sozusagen die nehmen
über wenn man also eine bevölkerung der
sucht blickt man in die vergangenheit
wer hat irgendwann schon mal diese
infektion durchgemacht bildet antikörper
aus hoffentlich und dann kann man die
zusammenzählen das ist wir nennen das
eine kumulative darstellung was wir aber
brauchen ist und man kann damit das will
ich nicht abstreiten und das haben wir
auf dem papier gemacht auch eine
ungefähre abschätzung der dunkelziffer
machen aber das ist halt sehr
fehleranfällig weil wir nicht wissen wie
lang der antikörper anhalten ob
überhaupt alle antikörper kriegen und
über die akute situation haben wir keine
ahnung
deswegen ist der absolute standard wenn
man eine epidemie hat wo symptomlose
personen
diese epidemie weiter tragen dass werden
da eine repräsentative kohorte übrigens
nicht nur von einem geburtsjahrgangs
sondern wie bei der werbung also 20.000
leute nach stadt land mann frau als in
allen kriterien gut gemischt beobachtet
und da die pc oder heute ein schnelltest
alle woche alle zwei wochen machen das
hätten bestimmt auch viele deutsche mit
wer soll die durch und dann zu sehen wo
wirklich akute infektion auf
das wäre die aufgabe für robert
auch institute gewesen und was ist was
ist in ihren augen der grund warum das
robert koch institut das nicht macht
sind die nicht einfach überlastet auch
aufgrund der sehr hohen anforderungen
die wir gerade haben
diese frage höre ich sozusagen täglich
mehrfach
ich kann ihnen das nicht sagen das
robert koch institut ist politisch
gesteuert und und wäre ist ja dem
bundesministerium für gesundheit
untergeordnet und da müssten sie damit
ihrer frage einmal aufschlagen
also sie werfen quasi dem rk ii vor dass
es nicht wissenschaftlich neutral
arbeitet ich sag nur einfach wir
brauchen zahlen wir sind im bereich der
mutmaßungen es werden grundrechte
eingeschränkt ohne dass wir eigentlich
genau verwertbare zahlen haben und ich
halte das als wissenschaftler aber ich
sage es doch hoffen auch ganz als bürger
für ein unding dass wir ohne eine feste
zahlenbasis zu solchen einschränkungen
schreiben und vor allen dingen das
probate methoden die überall bekannt
sind die jeder der sich
epidemiologischen infektion los betätigt
hat kennt die zum standard repertoire
gehören
und da ist unsere autorengruppe nicht
ohne grund hinterher dass immer wieder
einzufordern
aber es gibt ja zahlen auf die immer
wieder verwiesen wird also wir haben
einmal die infektionszahlen dann gibt es
den erwert dann haben wir eine ungefähre
ahnung davon wie viele intensivbetten
noch frei sind also es ist ja nicht so
dass wir im nebel durch die gegend
schwimmen doch diese muss ich ihnen
leider widersprechen diese täglich
erhobenen infektionszahlen sind von
nebel nicht weit entfernt wir testen
eineinhalb millionen leute in der woche
und haben dann meinetwegen 120000 test
positive aber wenn man zweieinhalb
millionen leute testen würden wie viel
hätten wir dann das hat keine basis
diese zahlen sind also wir drücken uns
mittlerweile relativ deutlich aus das
papier nicht wert auf dem es geschrieben
ist und schon gar nicht können sie damit
politisch steuert diese zahlen werden
erhoben und dann auf die
gesamtbevölkerung
berechnet ohne ein zu berechnen wie viel
in der gesamtbevölkerung dennoch
zusätzlich vielleicht infiziert sind
diese zahlen sind nichts wert ich habe
hier eine entgegnung von professor karl
lauterbach spd gesundheitsexperte der
hat mich kurz vor der sendung hier
erreicht also quasi während ich hier
schon stand und darauf wartet dass es
losging kam das immer ein
e-mail-postfach deswegen weiß ich nicht
ob das jetzt die entgegnung ist auf das
was wir gerade besprechen ich hoffe es
einfach mal und würde jetzt hier mal die
kollegen bitten auf meinen rechner zu
schalten und dann würde ich mal auf play
drücken
die studie selbst gibt keinen grund für
einen strategiewechsel zu machen die
hohen dunkelziffer die hier angenommen
wird die gibt es in deutschland nicht
und zum paten die strategie die wir
bisher verwenden hat gewirkt die
abschottung der risikopatienten es in
deutschland nicht praktikabel wir müssen
bis zur impfung durchhalten und die
bewährte strategie weiter fahren
so ich glaube das hat inhaltlich ganz
gut gepasst also herr lauterbach sagt es
gibt die dunkelziffer so wie sie sie
annehmen nicht wie kommen sie denn
darauf dass wir so eine hohe
dunkelziffer haben sehr guter torwart
die bemerkung von ihm kennt man ja er
ist weder infektiologe noch epidemiologe
also wir haben die studien genommen die
es in deutschland gibt die wir also als
antikörper studien und haben das
ausführlich dargestellte müsste das nur
lesen und dann würde ja sehen dass die
schätze und das für eine dunkelziffer
von faktor 2 bis faktor 7 haben zb aus
der großen münchner studie abgeleitet
absolut zutreffend ist aber bei der gold
standard die vorderste reihe münchen
nicht auf die ganz oft ganz deutschland
hochrechnen das ist ja auch nicht so
einfach es ist richtig aber es ist
immerhin ein kleiner zipfel der wahrheit
die wir darüber kennen und herr
lauterbach ist er selbst mit dran
schuldig weil er die ganze zeit ja die
notwendigkeit mich wahr haben will des
rekorden studium brauchen dass wir
nichts besseres haben
ich bin gerade ein bisschen irritiert
dass sie sagen dass er kein epidemiologe
ist nach meinen informationen hatte
epidemiologie an der harvard school of
public health der harvard universität
studiert ob er einen abschluss daran
hält kann ich gerade nicht sagen aber es
würde ich nochmal kurz einräumen weil
sie da seine expertise angegriffen haben
was ist das aber auch ihr verdienst
während investigativen journalismus
darauf das zu hinterfragen was sie
gerade gesagt haben gut das besprechen
ein andermal wir reden jetzt hier über
ihre thesen papier ich habe hier noch
einige kommentare also ich müsste mich
ein bisschen durchwühlen weil es sind
wie immer sehr sehr viele hier gibt es
zum beispiel einen kommentar von einem
user mit dem binärcode den ich nicht
lesen kann er oder sie schreibt ich
freue mich auf mittwoch endlich
schärfere massnahmen damit ist der
letzte ignorant kapiert dann gibt es
einen youtube kommentar armin nix nix
wir kommen nicht gut durch die krise in
der ersten welle waren es noch die über
80 an den krankenhäusern
jetzt sind es die fünfziger das kann das
gesundheitssystem rein wegen der zahlen
überlasten und auch der dfl auf youtube
schreibt bitte mehr schutz der
risikogruppen und weniger
einschränkungen für die allgemeinheit
besonders die kinder leiden unter den
maßnahmen wir haben mal geschaut wie es
denn tatsächlich jetzt aussieht mit den
belastungen der alten- und pflegeheime
und da hat mein kollege benno krieger
folgendes für uns zusammen gestellt dass
corinna virus trifft besonders die
älteren hat gut 86 prozent der korona
toten sind mindestens 70 jahre alt diese
zahlen rücken pflegeeinrichtungen in den
fokus von 14.000 22 corona toten
insgesamt starben nach angaben des
robert koch instituts knapp 5000
menschen in einrichtungen wie alten- und
pflegeheim
demnach entfallen ein drittel der korona
toten auf diese einrichtung noch
drastischer ist die aktuelle lage in
hessen laut dem regierungspräsidium
gießen starben dort zwischen dem zweiten
und dem 18 november 272 menschen an
cupid 19
allein 174 davon entfallen auf
altenheime in hessen sind demnach knapp
zwei drittel der korona toten im
november in altenheim gestorben also
dass eine momentaufnahme aufnahme
zumindest aus hessen patientenvertreter
kritisieren das ganze natürlich scharf
diesen zustand zb eugen brysch der erst
vor dessen der deutschen patienten der
stiftung patientenschutz und der hat da
uns sehr deutliche worte in die kamera
gesagt es ist vollkommen unverständlich
dass im neunten monat der pandemie es
immer noch nicht gelingt 900.000
pflegebedürftige in den heimen aber auch
drei millionen die zu hause leben
ausreichend zu schützen
wir müssen deshalb auch die pflegekräfte
mit in den blick nehmen das heißt wir
brauchen einen infektions grundschutz
eine kontakt dokumentation wer hat wann
wen wo gepflegt besucht betreut darüber
hinaus in regelmäßige pcr-test
unabdingbar
es kann auch nicht sein dass man darauf
tage warten muss um das ergebnis zu
haben und ergänzend dazu schnelltests
schnelltest die jeden tag dokumentieren
ist da jemand infektiös gerade von den
altenpflegekräften von den besucherinnen
und besuchern aber auch von den
therapeuten
wenn ich etwas tatsächlich erreichen
will in dieser krise dann muss ich dort
aktiv engagiert mit allen konzepten
arbeiten wo das problem entsteht nämlich
in der altenpflege wenn ich alleine
anfangen mir über die krankenhäuser
gedanken zu machen dann ist es schon
viel zu spät dann haben wir uns schon in
solidarisiert von den menschen die mir
eigentlich retten wollen so und darüber
diskutieren wir mit professor matthias
schrappe uni köln infektiologe und
internist jetzt muss ich noch mal auf
die kommentare eingehen weil das mal
wieder gerade bei dem thema hoch und
runter geht also sehr viele emotionale
kommentare ich nehme jetzt einen hier
raus hatte henriette sambona die
schreibt unfassbar was hier verbreitet
wird wie fühlen sie sich dabei die
menschen sollen kirre gemacht werden
liebe frau sei wohl das hat mit kirre
machen hier nichts zu tun was wir hier
versuchen ist quasi beste gelebte
demokratie nämlich im streit der
argumente und der fakten und der
deutungen der fakten miteinander
herauszufinden was die beste strategie
ist das machen andere länder ganz anders
zum beispiel china da wird einfach von
oben diktiert was zu tun ist und dann
setzen dass alle um ich glaube da wollen
wir nicht hin da wird wahrscheinlich
auch professor schrappe kurz nicken
denn das ist ja doch das was wir hier
wollen wir wollen miteinander reden und
diskutieren
ich kann jetzt noch mal sagen hier dass
einige sich sehr kritisch äußern
überhaupt wieder über den pcr test das
haben wir glaube ich auch schon häufig
besprochen hier im stream der pcr test
ist zuverlässig und ja das virus wurde
auch schon isoliert das haben wir alles
schon besprochen und ist quasi können
ihren haken hinter machen was wir hier
reden möchten ist der schutz der alten
der pflegebedürftigen da hatte ich auch
gerade einen kommentar hier von andreas
stolz auf facebook welche konkreten
maßnahmen zum schutz der risikogruppen
die ja weit mehr umfassen als nur die in
den alten und pflegeheim schlagen sie
denn vorher schrappe ich muss sagen in
ihrem thesenpapier habe ich dazu auch
wenig gefunden bis gar nichts außer die
forderung
dass man zielgruppenspezifische
maßnahmen ergreifen sollte welche wären
das
na gut also sie haben ja selbst gesagt
dass wir bis jetzt sechs thesenpapiere
verfasst haben und das letzte
thesenpapier also nummer 5 sind 50
seiten voller konkreter vorschläge wie
man zur zielgruppenorientierten
spezifischen prävention kommen kann ja
noch nicht gefallen und rassisten weil
ich habe nicht nein nicht die zeit
gehabt in zwei tagen uns design materie
zu lesen
gut ja ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen
weil sie sozusagen unterstellen wir
würden etwas behaupten und hätten dazu
nichts gesagt wir haben uns die ganze
zeit über mit konkreten vorschlägen
nicht hinterm berg gehalten und haben
das jetzt auch vor bereits vier wochen
nochmal zusammengefasst ich sage ein
beispiel nicht mehr brysch hat ja völlig
richtig die situation in den
pflegeheimen angesprochen
die ist mit unseren grundsätzen von
würde und humanität nicht zu vereinen
was da passiert das ist nicht die schuld
der heime oder der mitarbeiter oder
mitarbeiterinnen da sondern das ist
einfach angelegt durch die durch die
notstandsgesetze die dort aufgetreten
ist
sie herr frisch hat das thema
schnelltest angesprochen warum fragen
wir nicht studenten oder andere personen
die ihre ich sag mal kleinen jobs als
als kellner zum beispiel verloren haben
weil die restaurants geschlossen sind
umfragen mir die nicht dass sie in einem
wagen wo es teste gibt sich am abend
oder am nachmittag des vortages
vorhinein positionieren und die enkel
oder die töchter und söhne testen lassen
und wenn die beim negativen test am
nächsten morgen da kann man sogar die
pcr nehmen per sms darüber informiert
werden das sind negativ sind könnte ich
den ganzen tag ihre großeltern eltern
besuchen
warum haben wir als gesellschaft nicht
die fantasie zur verfügung zu solchen
methoden zu kommen
wir haben dazu zahlreiche aufgeführt wir
haben den eindruck dass die blockade auf
der politischen ebene liegt auf der
obersten politischen ebene die einfach
nicht den richtungswechsel in gang
setzen möchte und endlich dieses thema
anpacken möchte aber was ist denn der
grund dafür wenn wir uns noch anschauen
wie dort bundesregierung und die
regierungen der länder miteinander
ringen und miteinander streiten und auch
sehr unterschiedlicher meinung sind
maßnahmen zu verschärfen oder nicht zu
verschärfen zu verlängern letzte woche
gab es nur appelle ist ja der eindruck
zumindest aus meiner seite jetzt nicht
so vehement dass dort einfach stur an
einer maßnahme oder einrichtungen
festgehalten wird da wird jedoch
miteinander diskutiert ja es wird
diskutiert aber nur über die eine sache
wie wie schafft der lock down ist und
wie lange anhält ich habe da noch keine
fruchtbare diskussion aber nur im
entferntesten mitbekommen wo man sich
mal differenziert darüber unterhält für
schutzmaßnahmen und schutzstrategien
wären auch wird von der politischen
führung unseres landes das zwar per
lippenbekenntnis gelegentlich gesagt und
steht auch in den papieren drin aber
dass da mal jemand für die kamera treten
würde und sagt liebe mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger wir haben ja ein riesenproblem
über den winter wie können wir das am
besten machen wir sammeln mal ideen wir
nehmen gelten die hand wir neben
engagement die hand nehmen
zivilgesellschaftliches engagement in
die hand und probieren dinge mal aus und
ich bin sicher das würde einen umschwung
in der bestimmung bedeuten die leute
würden nicht nur mit beton szenarien
konfrontiert und es würde auch sehr viel
produktives dabei rauskommen aber es
wird gar nicht versucht und die
diskussionen die sie ansprechen in den
gremien sind in einer form diskurs
verengt was uns schon auf die dauer in
unserer autorengruppe sehr bedenklich
hat werden lassen
haben sie eine erklärung dafür dass die
regierenden sich für diese vorschläge
die sie haben nicht öffnen
ich möchte analog zur frage von folien
antworten
es ist eine frage die sie an die
verantwortlichen stellen müssen ich kann
nicht die politische führung
interpretieren dieses landes das steht
mir nicht zu
und ich bin auch nicht der richtige
adressat aber die stellen fest sie haben
deutliche und massive kritik am vorgehen
der bundesregierung und auch der
landesregierungen haben jetzt das extra
thesen papier geschrieben werden sie an
70 schreiben ja wir haben dieses
thesenpapier wie eine einleitung steht
jetzt unterteilt in drei verschiedene
dieses jetzt in app ideologisches papier
richtig auch mit begriffsklärung was ist
wie incidents ist es was völlig anderes
als das was vom rk ii gebraucht wird das
nächste papier wird wieder zur
prävention gehen wir werden noch neue
gedanken versuchen aufzunehmen und dann
werden wir wieder ein papier zu den
gesellschaftspolitischen konsequenzen
und zu den rechtlichen grund rechtlichen
folgen entwerfen so weit als
ehrenamtlicher hat ehrenamtliche unsere
kraft reicht
also ich schaue noch mal in die
kommentare professor schrappe ob
irgendwas ist was ich an sie
weiterreichen kann
die wir jetzt versuchen können mal
zusammen zu beantworten hier ist eine
frage von julia feller dies noch ganz
interessant finde wie soll denn konkret
risikopatienten die etwa 40 prozent der
gesellschaft ausmachen das ist jetzt
eine frage der interpretation aber das
nehme ich mir einfach so hin die zahl
konkret geschützt werden ohne dass man
sie wegsperrt da der herr also
angesprochen sind sie sich hier auch um
die grundrechte kümmern wie bekommen wir
denn den schutz der risikogruppe mit
artikel 1 und 2 unseres grundgesetzes
zusammen also gibt es eine andere
möglichkeit ohne diese menschen
wegzusperren fragt julia fehler
das ist eine sehr wichtige frage ich
mich sozusagen dafür bedanken weil das
an ein kernproblem gehört nicht wenn wir
offensichtlich in unserer gesellschaft
über den schutz sprechen von
wohlgeratenen verletzlichen gruppen und
personen fällt uns das wegsperren immer
als erstes sein
wir sind deswegen schon im zweiten
thesenpapier im sommer hin
und haben eine art algorithmus eine
einen score entworfen
wo wir spezifiziert haben wie eigentlich
solche schutzbedürftigen personen zu
charakterisieren sind und da ist die hat
die prüferin völlig recht das alter ist
nur eines unter vielen kriterien
wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal das
wichtigste denn ein gesunder 70-jähriger
mann oder eine gesunde 70er frau muss
deswegen nicht besonders anfällig seien
aber wenn sie zusätzlich diabetes hat
oder wenn sie zusätzlich in einer
institution lebt die anfällige suite
solche pflegeheim oder ambulant gepflegt
wird oder kann haus kontakt hatte in der
letzten zeit dann sind das sozusagen
risiko punkte die man wenn man
verständigt damit umgehen würde und
diese diskussion überhaupt erstmal
anfangen würde jemand zu einem
sinnvollen instrument entwickeln könnte
aber wir haben in der politik keinerlei
reaktion auf diese sehr differenzierte
instrument empfohlen
was wir aber hatten professor strafe
waren ja diskussionen als das doch sehr
regional unterschiedlich gehandhabt
wurde hieß das ist es ein flickenteppich
ich habe das wort auch benutzen muss ich
selbstkritisch sagen andere fragen jetzt
hier auf youtube zum beispiel david
konnte er kurz ganz angucken noch mal
auf meinem recht glauben sie wirklich
dass andere maßnahmen flächendeckend
umgesetzt werden könnten bei 80
millionen menschen die unterschiedlicher
nicht sein können ich denke nicht also
da haben wir wieder die nächste
diskussion
sie plädieren quasi für differenzierte
maßnahmen andere sagen das funktioniert
doch gar nicht beziehungsweise als wir
versucht haben sie umzusetzen gab es
auch wieder kritik daran dass gesagt
wurde das ist alles ein flickenteppich
können wir überhaupt aus dieser
situation rauskommen ohne dass immer
eine doch signifikante gruppe sich immer
beschwert wer natürlich also politik und
gesellschaft wie es leben ist nun mal
von den widerspruch zwischen
differenzierung und allgemeinem geprägt
da raus kommen wir nicht weg wir sind
eine differenzierte gesellschaft das ist
aber kein argument dass dafür dass man
die disco
schon gar nicht erst anfängt und der
begriff flickenteppich wenn ich das mal
so einflechten darf stammt ja daraus
dass wir aus bundesländern einen art
wettlauf um ja die schärfsten und
tollsten maßnahmen erlebt haben die
eigentlich mehr mit wahlkampf allüren zu
tun hatten und weniger von wirklichen
epidemiologische für die infektion
logischen tatsachen getragen war sagt
professor schrappe universität köln
infektiologe und ein kritiker der
derzeitigen maßnahmen hat ein
thesenpapier geschrieben mit vielen
kolleginnen zusammen kann man im netz
auf seiner homepage in ganzer länge
lesen
das mag hat ja heute abend war noch ein
bisschen was zu tun sechs thesenpapiere
gibt es schon professor schrappe vielen
dank dass sie heute abend zeit für uns
hatten
und vielen dank für eure fragen und
hatte auch wenn sie nicht immer als
gefreut lich waren aber darüber sehen
wir heute mal großzügig hinweg und sagen
dass zum nächsten mal einen schönen
abend noch und tschüss